الخريطه التفاعليه وكيف تمكن الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان من حسم الجوله
الثانيه رغم انه لم يتمكن من حسم انقره
ولا اسطنبول الا انه تمكن كما تشاهدون بعد
فرس 99% من صناديق الاقتراع من حسم
النتيجه وبفارق مريح يتجاوز تقريبا
مليونين ومئه الف مئه صوت تحديدا حتى الان
وما زال هناك بعض الحسابات فيما يتعلق
باغلاق صناديق
بعض المناطق المطارات وغيرها في اللحظات
الاخيره يمكن ان يتم حساب مئه في المئه
عندما نتحدث عن الفرق بين الرئيس التركي
رجل طيب اردوغان وكمالك في هذه الجوله
نتحدث عن رقم يعتبر كبير مليونين
و172,000 لكن لا يعني بالضروره ان كمالك
الجداره لم يحقق تقدما في هذه الجوله لكنه
لم يحقق التقدم المطلوب كان منذ الجوله
الاولى واضحا ان الرئيس التركي تقدم بفارق
مليونين ونصف المليونين المليون في في
الجوله الاولى الان
الامور على ما هي عليه بالنسبه للفرق
بينهما
فيد وهنا بعد قليل نتحدث عن كيف خسر
كمالكيش دارول رغم تقدمه حتى في ديار بكر
في ديار بكر تقريبا حصل على نفس النسبه
المئويه في المره الماضيه 71% وواحد وستين
في ديار بكر بينما الرئيس التركي تقريبا
حصل على نفس النسبه في الجوله في الماضيه
لان سنان اوغان تقريبا ليس له حضور في
ديار بكر ولم تتاثر كثيرا لكن في حقيقه
الامر الاصوات وسنناقش تفاصيلها مع صهيب
العصا بعد قليل هناك اشكاليه حصلت في ديار
بكر ونحتاج ان نفصل اكثر كيف مع ارتفاع او
حصول كمالك على ولايات كبيره ديار بكر اضن
في الجنوب نتعلم عن ونتكلم عن اسطنبول وعن
انقره
وليس فرق كبير عن الجولات السابقه الا في
معينه اين هي صحيح تحدث بشكل اساسي عن
المناطق الشرقيه من البلاد عبد السلام اذا
ما تحدثنا حتى نقارن بين الخريطتين الجوله
الاولى والجوله الثانيه هذه خريطه تركيا
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه في هذه الجوله حصل
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان على 52.87 وحصلت
على
47.3% ونلاحظ اعاده التلوين في الخريطه
الذي حصل هذه الخريطه الجوله الثانيه التي
نتحدث عنها ويجب ان نلاحظ نراقب هذه
المنطقه منطقه هاتاي التي تلونت باللون
البرتقالي بعد ان كانت في الجوله السابقه
قد حسمت لل لكمال كالجدار اوغلو كما نشاهد
على الخريطه كانت هنا وتلونت باللون
الاحمر صحيح ان الفرق لم يكن كبيرا بين
الرجلين في الجوله الاولى ولم يكن كبيرا
ايضا في هذه الجوله في الجوله الاولى
هاتاي نتحدث عن 49 عفوا هذه بالنسبه عموم
البلاد نتحدث عن هاتاي
الجوله الاولى كان نصف نصف درجه في المئه
في الجوله في الجوله السابقه وهذا الامر
انعكس الان لصالح اردوغان كان لصالح جدار
طبعا اكثر من مره انه كان هناك نقط كبير
لمناطق هاتاي تحديدا
في البرلمانيات وايضا الان في الرئاسيات
فكان هناك غضب شديد على سكان مناطق
الزلازل اضيفت الانهاطايا للولايات الاخرى
التي اعطت اردوغان في الجوله الاولى اذا
ما راقبنا مثلا عبد السلام هذه الجوله
الاولى اذا ما راقبنا الجوله الثانيه فنحن
نتحدث عن منطقتين رئيسيتين منطقه
كهرمان مراش وهي صاحبه اعلى فرق في
التصويت لصالح اردوغان ارتفعت من الجوله
الاولى اعطت مكان الفرق بين اردوغان
وكالجدار اوغلو في الجوله الاولى 49 نقطه
في المئه في الجوله الثانيه اعطت اردوغان
بكثافه اكثر فارت الفارق الى ثلاثه الى
51% فاصبح الفرق نقطتين مئوتان لصالح
اردوغان في كهرمان مرش بينما الامر في
ديار بكر كان مختلفا صحيح ان ديار بكر
كانت صاحبه اعلى تصويت لمرشح وصل الى 71
في المئه تقريبا في الجوله الاولى اعطت
كهرمان ديار بكر اعطت
71% فكان الفرق بين اردوغان
وكما جدار اوغلو في الديار بكر حوالي 45%
في في ديار بكر نقص العدد من 45 نقطه
لصالح كمالك الى 43 نقطه يعني نتحدث عن
نقطتين مئويتان نزولا
الفارق تقلصه وهذا الامر مستند الاله قد
يكون الى 30 الف صوت 30,000
الى العزوف في التصويت نسبه التصويت في
شكل عام في عم البلاد انخفضت بنسب متفاوته
بين واحد الى اربعه في المئه الى خمسه في
المئه فروق التصويت الامر البارز كان هبوط
نسبه التصويت في هذه المناطق المناطق
الكرديه التي كان من المفترض ان تقلب
الطاوله لصالح كمال بهذه لا يتاثر كثيرا
بمناطق الاكراد على العكس هو تاثر ايجابا
لنا نسبه المشاركه انخفضت وبالتالي تقلص
الفارق بينه وبين كمالك جدار اوغلو عن
الجوله الاولى وبالتالي تقدم في هذه
الجوله الثانيه اذا ما تحدثنا عن ابرز
ملامح التصويت على هذه الخريطه ماذا ماذا
ترى عبد السلام يعني عندما نقول ان ازمير
مثلا اذا اردنا نتحدث عن هل كماله الجداره
حشد لهذه الجوله ام لا في ازمير نعم حشد
ورفع نسبه التصويت لكن لم تكن كافيه ليرفع
نسبه نسبته في كل المناطق ارتفعت في
انطاليا لكن ايضا لم تكن ارتفاعا كبيرا
رغم انه يضل يعني 50 في بعض المناطق
100,000 في بعض المناطق حتى في اسطنبول
ارتفعت اصوات كمالك الجدار اوغلو ولكن عدم
تصويت مناطق الاكراد لصالح كمالك
مثلا خسر 40 الف صوت مهمه في المجمل
اذا اكثر مناطق تاثر فيها كماله الجدار
اوغلو هي مناطق الاكراد بينما المناطق
التي تاثرت ورفعت نسبه اردوغان هي مناطق
الزلزال صحيح اذا ما انتقلنا بشكل سريع
عبد السلام الى
ديارنا نتحدث عنها قبل قليل بانها كانت
اعلى نسبه تصويت لصالح
جدار اوغلو حصل فيها على حوالي 71% ولكن
الان نتحدث عن الفارق في التصويت بين
الرجلين صحيح يمكن القول بانها بقيت مع
كمالك الجدار اوغلو ولكن كما ذكرنا انخفض
الفارق بين خطايانا يا جماعه هذا الفرز
الارقام معكوسه 71% لكم جدا
انخفض الفارق من كما تحدثنا من 45 نقطه في
ديار بكر الى 43 نقطه صحيح ان تقدم تقدم
بقي متقدما كالاصدار اوغلو ولكن الفارق
كان لصالح العزوف عن التصويت كان لصالح
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان لتكون هذه الجوله
جوله نسبه المشاركه هي التي حسمت فيها
اكثر نعم عندي ملاحظه لو رجعنا للخريطه
الملونه لهذه الفتره الجوله الثانيه نعم
انا وانت سالنا في البدايه هل هناك تاثير
لسنان عندما ننظر الى
مسقط راس ولايه بسيطه من حيث الحجم
التصويطي لكن كنا نريد ان نقيس هل
استفاد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان من
اصوات سنان اوغان اتضح لي هنا انه كان
اردوغان
25% الان قارب 34% فهناك تاثير سنان كان
حصل على 11% في يدر فهناك تاثير ايجابي
كتله التصويتيه
اتبعت قراره بهذا ربنا
ليس بالضروره وارتفعت اصوات اردوغان في
عدد من المناطق في اسطنبول مثلا لكنه لم
يستعد ايوب سلطان ولم يستعد اسكوبار
وظل متاخرا في كثير من الاحياء ولذلك لم
يحسمها ايضا في انقره
كان كمالك حسن ثلاث مناطق او احياء رئيسيه
اضيف لها حي اخر من حساب اردوغان في هذه
الجوله اربعه احياء ذهبت من انقره في حين
في 2018 كان فقط حي واحد ذوق يعني عدد
كبير تركيز كبير انتخابي لصالح كماله وكان
اردوغان فائز فيها بفرق ثلاثه احياء مهمه
خسرها الجوله الثانيه بالنسبه لنسبه
التصويت لاحظنا ان نسبه التصويت نزلت
ونسبه التصويت نزلت نزولا كبيرا في بعض
المناطق على خمسه هبوط في نسبه المجمل 3%
المعدل 300 ولكن بعض المناطق هبطت الى
اكثر من ذلك
كيف يمكن قراءه هذا النزول على تاثيره على
نتائج الانتخابات طبيعه الحال عندما نتحدث
في تركيا اي شخص في تركيا يعرف انه ليس كل
الناس يسكنون في ذات المناطق التي يصوتون
فيها فمثلا شخص يعيش في اسطنبول لكنه في
دائره النفوس مسجل في انطاليا فلابد ان
يعود الى انطاليا وخلال اسبوعين عندما
تطالب كل هذه الشريحه بالعوده مره اخرى مع
التكاليف في التنقل لي فقط يوم واحد كثير
من الناس يتخاذل ولا يذهب هذا يفسر ربما
انخفاض نسبه التصويت اضف الى ذلك وهنا
مفارقه عجيبه انه على العكس من ذلك مناطق
الزلزال فيها انخفاض بسيط ولكن هناك اصوات
جاءت في المقابل يسموها اصوات انتقاميه
نظرا للحاله التي حصلت عندما هجموا
لتصويتهم هناك من نفس الشريحه من صوتوا
للرئيس مناطق لكن نسبه التصويت انخفضت في
في عموم المناطق من حيث نسبه المشاركه من
حيث نسبه المشاركه لكن هذا دليل على ان
الاصوات انتزعت انتزعا من كمالك وصبت في
صالح الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان نتوقع
عندها هذا الحد